police who detained reggae legend Bob
Marley's granddaughter in Southern
California say that race was not a
factor body cam footage of the incident
shows the moment Denisha Prendergast and
her friends were surrounded by police
well a neighbor reported them as they
left their Airbnb rental with their
luggage but a fnal is at the Rialto
Police Department east of Los Angeles
Matea good morning good morning
Denisha Prendergast has hired an
attorney and so she intends to sue the
Rialto Police Department on Instagram
she describes being left shaken by the
encounter and she wrote in a post that
she was left in a very safe unstable
situation she said I got surrounded by
police for being black in a white
neighborhood within minutes of leaving
their Airbnb rental Denisha Prendergast
and her three friends were blocked in by
police cars this is white lady sauce in
the neighborhood too many black folk
officers were responding to a 911 day
about a possible burglary involving
three black people and one white woman
no we're taking our suitcases and stuff
police let the group go after confirming
their story 22 minutes later if I vote
to be cleared up and you guys are gonna
feel so sorry
on Tuesday Rialto police released body
cam footage to counter perceptions on
social media that officers acted
inappropriately that video shows
Prendergast and her friends moving
around freely and joking with police
police also followed up with a 9-1-1
caller but only released the audio to
protect her identity
[Music]
interim police chief mark Ling says his
officers are being criticized even
though they were courteous and
professional social media is really a
challenge to a lot of police departments
and it's because of the inaccurate
information that just is like lighting a
wildfire
there are literally my first guests
Marie Roda Diaz owns the home listed on
air B&B since the incident she says
she's been threatened for defending the
police and her neighbor who became
suspicious because
prenderghast group didn't respond when
she waved at them strange vehicle
strange people in a suburban
neighborhood and they're not friendly
she called the police and I don't blame
her that neighbor did not want to go on
camera but she did tell me off-camera
that race had nothing to do with that
911 mate she's the neighborhood has had
a rash of burglaries over the last
several months and that's the exact
reason why she called she actually saw
an Amazon delivery truck leaving
Rodriguez's home just a few minutes
before waving to that group we did a
sprinter grass and her friends to talk
with us for this story but they declined
to go on camera I think you know it's so
easy to jump to race on stories like
this but when you look at it the
neighbor was concerned she called the
police they had the body cameras there
it seemed like the police were being
very respectful in that it was a good
exchange between the two we live in such
volatile times where you instantly throw
race at something but yeah looking at
that you I don't I don't see how you can
draw that conclusion looking at what we
just saw yeah a lot of hurt feelings yes
I think you know and maybe Lisa you know
this is the case the police did their
job that's right you know when you're
renting out your house let the neighbor
know so when they see people there right
that are not you that's a really good
point John yes the news you can use
fYI you're gonna see different people
walking in and out it's not gonna be me
for the next week